on this vote the yeas are 232 the nays
are 196 the impeachment inquiry is
formalized by Duty claim Democrats not
desire at the table I doubt anybody in
this place or anybody that you know
comes to Congress to take the oath of
office comes to Congress to impeach the
President of the United States unless
his actions are jeopardizing our
honoring our oath of office that say
Republicans is pure spin never forget
how this whole thing started
Democrats are trying to impeach the
President of the United States thirteen
months before an election based on an
anonymous whistleblower with no
first-hand knowledge who has a bias
against the president there is now a
resolution rules and plenty of rancor
we're here because of the president his
actions his jeopardizing our national
security for his own political gain the
woman at the helm says this is solely
about evidence do you think this vote
will do anything to diminish the
Republican and White House belief that
this is an illegitimate unfair and
partisan inquiry the facts are what they
are they can try to misrepresent them
but the fact is this is very this is a
process that is expanded opportunity for
them to show anything that is
exculpatory whose the innocence of the
president Donald Trump is only the
fourth president in US history to face
this challenge now the public will get
to watch the hearings
however divisive they may be today they
finally voted to actually create what
they've been doing for six weeks so it
shows that the last six weeks was
totally inappropriate we have rules that
govern this country does that mean you
don't think that the White House should
cooperate going forward there's no
evidence there will be new evidence new
witnesses
probably not new levels of cooperation
just a few months ago around 1/3 of
Democrats opposed an impeachment inquiry
now all but two have backed it but
Republicans have framed this as a
partisan probe from the start in this
vote will only add to their argument mr.
Trump has declared it the biggest witch
hunt in history whatever you call it
you'll soon be able to see it even if
you'd rather look away Cordelia Lynch
Sky News Washington